no episode about all things a little bit
extra would be complete without bloopers
i'm sure you thought everything goes
exactly according to plan
at all times around here right uh-uh
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how to make your eyes pop what's inside
your beauty box
wait that does not sound right
whoa
is it on oh my gosh wrong does it look
better your gray is gone
for real then load me up
look at him did it work i can't see
um jeremy has decided to uh do his
do her business and jeremy you did it on
the
oriental rug oh no
you know what this person does it makes
this banana go from this
to this that's a smile
last time asking
of old
right eight times the charm
dear drew what's wrong with you that it
that did it did that that that
love that that's that
[Music]
[Music]
designer nate berkus gives alison janney
a
perfect place for her pooch
sounded really fallacious
let me uh let me redo that one this i'm
not excited okay
i know oh my god
good thing we have a spit bucket isn't
this a nice one too
one two oh no i'm doing it i'm counting
to three
anything can you throw it to me one two
no
no yeah
one two three
the eb healing wings oh my goodness
they're gone
what oh the eb
healing wings butterfly
and co-design oh no oh no
darn it
is sh are people listening to this they
were weren't they though
[Music]
you